[Music]
see you in a little while see you I
think I suppose time is that your
Christmas party you know no one makes
you but you get me laughing so hard at a
Christmas party I got invited at Conan's
Christmas party yeah small intimate very
funny it's like a who's who of comedy
who is me and and I make good Tom Hanks
and Marty short and Adam Sandler yeah
they're just there all the time both at
a this party we got a weird roommate
situation were shooting at for reality
oh it's interesting yeah no that's the
damico thanks like air right no it was
it was it was fun you had a fun time but
I remember what I remember Brett that
was it was late and I was talking to you
and and outside you had these fire pits
no Jewish one just like one little fire
yeah by big fire pit and next to your
couch yeah it's very windy outside yeah
and I'm talking to you and in the back I
see the wind slowly moving the flames on
to the couch and the couch caught on
fire
wait how long were you watching the
flames for a very long time I didn't do
much I just was like oh hey that's
that's not right
hey anything no Sandler was like a code
and your couches on fire body was that
the bear from Ted Mark Wahlberg was like
a and then yeah Marty short was yeah
yeah throw it in the pool or whatever no
dramatic yeah he was like throw it in
the pool Liza everyone in the Nina to
dance confetti came by remember are you
sure yeah
but what I remember was when I pointed
out to you you what oh and then you're
analyzed at that point it was like I
would say fire it was 15 feet high
higher huge fire because the question
had got on fire and we just stared at it
and then your wife grad got the
extinguisher and ran out and put it out
I have a slightly different story I
remember Liza putting it I remember it a
slightly different story with that first
of all I think I saved your life
no I know I remember I did run out there
did run out I did run out there yeah
were you okay are you were you high what
what's going on I mean I did run out
there it's just that I didn't know
some of that market said throw it in the
pools it threw it in the pool
yeah and he said it just like that he
was wearing a monocle and so I'm driving
the pool for everyone and I started
dragging it towards the the pool when my
wife who's the smart one yeah came out
with a fire any minute we had a fire in
Shh oh just like yeah just knew exactly
where it was knew exactly what to do and
you came in try it act like nothing had
happened you'd smoke all over you anyway
as I was saying yeah as I was saying
great party I have fantastic party yeah
now that's the end of every story I have
every story ends with me turning to a
camera that's not there and going I have
fantastic part
you